if you thought this election couldn't
get any class here you were wrong
let's check out this exactly as you can
see no change from last week Donald
Trump still in the lead
especially after his big win in Arizona
and those 58 delegates Ted Cruz are
number one loser he got 40 delegates in
Utah but I'm not so sure it was fair and
square
ladies you're all the rage this week an
anti-trump Procrit out this ad and utah
meet Melania Trump your next first lady
or you could support a Cruz on Tuesday
that ad was for the Mormon
they're not really into the whole nudity
thing but I'm pretty sure the men of
America are especially donald's voters I
think you just helped him win more now
laying his emotions naked on the floor
Trump defended his wife's honor by
reminding America that Heidi Cruz might
be crazy push him too much and Donald
Trump might spill the beans
but what beans are they black beans or
brown beans what brand of bean and what
will the ensuing damage of the beans
they only got to down the top now the
truth about the base it's like Greek
tragedy except it's better because it's
all American and the media's go crazy
Cruz responded to the tweet by saying
that Heidi is way at at Trump's League
to which Donald retweeted a picture
showing that Melania is prettier than
Haddie - which Cruz responded by saying
this Donald real men don't attack women
your wife is lovely and Heidi is the
love of my life
I'd like to parse that one out for a
moment
Donald real men don't attack women aka
real men don't attack women unless the
poor Shh I'm not supposed to say that
out loud
as conservatives only like to imply
those things your wife is lovely
aka she's at my league and Haddie is the
love of my life
aka she's the only woman in America who
would sleep with me well her and the
other woman I'm probably cheating on her
with look America it's not that Donald
Trump is anti woman it's just that he's
Pro pretty women and honestly us women
are blessed with so many things our
monthly friends our ability to gain
weight without even trying the joys of
working the same job of being paid less
than men it's truly a gift to be
challenged at every turn
really it's an embarrassment of riches
thanks so much for watching and a huge
thank you to David Pakman for allowing
my conservative values on his channel
remember subscribe to his channel and
subscribe to my new Z news I'll see
y'all next week bye